hi everyone welcome back I'm Sam from
Pixie whoop and today we're going to be
talking about nude lips how to wear them
what colors in particular we're going to
be talking about Kate Moss's new
collection for Rimmel it's called the
Kate nude collection and there is a
bunch of different new to for different
skin tones their nude lips have been
around forever and we love them because
they give us such diversity with our
makeup they mean that we can wear a very
very strong smoky eye or a strong bright
blush and it will balance it perfectly
likewise if you don't wear a lot of
makeup it's a great way to just wear a
little bit and makes a dramatic
difference now we wouldn't put our
foundation on without a primer or a
moisturizer underneath so if it looks
fresh and healthy the same can be said
for the lips so Kate has launched this
amazing lip balm so fuller healthier
lips start with a lip balm this
particular lip conditioner has an SPF of
15 it's really comfy
it's got non sticky formula and it's
going to last on the lips up to eight
hours it's a brilliant partner for a
lipstick because it means that your
lipstick is going to go on smoother but
actually you can wear it on its own and
if anything is the perfect nude because
it's your lip color what brilliant idea
for K to bring out the nude collection
when I think of Kate Moss although she
looks stunning in red I always think of
her in a nude lip and she's done so well
here because the honest truth is quite
often when we talk about new we don't
think about what nude is and nude is
actually different to everyone
what is new to my skin is going to be
very different to what's nude on
somebody with a really fair skin or the
other end of the spectrum and really
dark skin and what cake done is bring
our immune for everyone I'm going to
show you a few of these and I'm going to
try them on just so you can see the
differences and how they work I'm going
to start with 40 this is a pale nude
it's particularly good for people with a
little bit of an oily skin tone or a
little bit of tan now this color is
pretty pale on me but I can make it work
really easily with a lip pencil this is
exaggerated pencil and the color is
addiction now I'm just going to fill in
the outside corners
so if you're fair like me and you feel
like that pale dick color really washes
you out then just add a little lip liner
so you get that little bit of contrast
and then it will look great next we've
got number 43 this is a tan nude now
this is an excellent nude I love this
one it looks good on so many different
skin tones but it also gives us the
option to play up the eyes a little so
I'm going to take a little bit of this
this is Rimmel VIP pass it's one of the
magnifies eye shadows and I'm just going
to blend a little of that just through
the socket and let's pop a slick of
wonderful mascara on top of our lashes
this mascara is got argan oil in so it's
really great for keeping eyelashes in
tip-top condition back on with a lip
conditioner okay
my third color I love this one this is
actually my favorite and this one is I
find it it's 48 now 48 would look great
on a darker skin tone but I really love
the color on me if I use it quite
tightly so I'm going to use it over my
lip balm I love this color I feel like
it looks like my lips only better
especially when it's mixed in with that
lip conditioner but if you want to go
darker you can
as you can see it would make the most
sensational nude on a darker skin tone
with this eyeshadow in this lip it gives
you a really nice balance probably
wouldn't need to put too much on the
cheeks it gives you quite a nice nude
but glam evening look
there are a ton more colors in this
range I have a couple more I can show
you this is 42 it's an apricot nude so
if you wanted something a little lighter
than the tan nude this is so pretty and
45 which is a rose nude so if you want a
pinky nude this might be just the one
for you the lip conditioning balm and
the lasting finish lipsticks are five
pound 49 each so get yourself a bargain
also 99% of the looks I saw on the
catwalk for spring/summer this season
are completely nude lips so you're going
to be well on trend as well and that is
everything for today but before I go I'm
just going to run you through the
products that I'm wearing I have on the
Rimmel match perfection foundation and
then as I showed you earlier I put a VIP
pass through the socket and all over the
lid I actually have this which is one of
my favorites in the moment which is
millionaire this is one of them
magnifies eyeshadows and I love it it's
my daily wash up color across my eyelid
mascara I showed you which is wonderful
and you know the lips because it is my
favorite number 48 thank you so much for
watching and I'll see you next time take
care bye bye